it's more important to exercise the mind  than it is to exercise the body  okay  i now know my answer i'm trying to think  of your  answer i've been working out  like i could tell you can tell us  shoulders getting wider yeah no less so  i got this right you're telling me  yes or no i don't okay because i don't  know why  i think they're both actually equally  important that's what i'm saying i think  that you need  both because if you're a  fat whale  but your mind is like that affects your  mind too if you're putting horrible  things into your body yes it also  affects your mind if you're eating  mcdonald's every day that's bad for your  thinking yes no i well yeah i mean it's  it's delicious but it's probably not  great for your thinking and and this pro  i mean i i say this is someone who  hasn't worked out you know since the  clinton administration i'll take you to  work out i thought it would be great